25 years since they first formed travis
are not only still performing
they are challenging for number one in
the album charts and in keeping with the
times
their latest project has a social
distancing story
let's have a look
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
well the lead singer fran healy is with
us now hello to you fran it's good to
talk to you good morning good morning
um 25 years since travis started to play
together and you're back with a new
album good on you
yeah yeah thank you thank you for having
us
me tell me a bit more about it
well we um yeah it's been a little while
four years
since uh since we were since we last had
a record out and then
we've we basically we finished the album
luckily
just before the the pandemic
lockdown and then all of the videos and
all of the artwork and everything was
done
by me in the lockdown um
it's kind of like a blue peter effort
tell me about how difficult it was doing
those videos though during social
distancing because i mean we we operate
that every day here
in the studio but it's tricky well
you know the animation that you're
watching just now that was the easiest
one because
you know it's just me sitting in my room
for
ages just drawing but the the other
video is we the latest single is a song
with um
the bangle singer susanna hawthorne i
had to shoot
the boys in the band in glasgow i had to
shoot susannah in los angeles and me and
another location and then sew it all
together so it all looked like that we
were in one place
and that was that was a bit of a
nightmare but it's it's fine you sort of
you just get on with it like you
you know like you were saying you guys
do it everyone has to
just get on with it okay and are you
planning a tour
what's the plan with that obviously we
need to wait until after christmas at
least
yeah well we have a tour at the end of
april and may
it's kind of booked and we're just like
everyone else
can us waiting for the hopefully fingers
crossed we can
this this will go ahead and so far so
good
yeah um it's what 25 years since the ban
was first formed did you think that you
would still be
rocking it 25 years later
did i think i'd be sitting looking like
a plumber on sky tv
25 years later um
yeah i don't know i i think we you
you just go day to day and you go oh
well i hope that um
i hope that i can do this tomorrow and
and i think
everyone all the musicians i meet we
always say to one another god we're
still getting away with it
so um i'm happy to still be getting away
with it
okay well i wasn't going to bring up um
the uh super mario outfit friend but
seeing as you did tell us a bit more
about it
well i am it's it's i thought i want to
have a uniform for this
record and i got this red jumpsuit thing
just for stage for running around on
stage because
for the last you know 20 years you know
you wear jeans on
stage and it's really hard to like i i'm
quite
physical i'd run around and then you
know jump off the drum kit and
run you know into the crowd and then
i got this jumpsuit and i thought oh
that's good i can i can move around and
um
i um we did a show in october
wearing it and it looked amazing it
looked great so i thought i'll just wear
it for the
for the for the for the record and it
saves me
worrying about what i'm gonna
maybe said that one time when you finish
with it so we look forward to seeing you
april may time
but in the meantime good luck with the
album is doing incredibly well
in the album charts and we're going to
leave the we're going to leave you with
one of your old songs for the benefit of
our viewers come back and talk to us
anytime good to talk to you friend thank
you
thank you bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes